[Music]
hey what's up mkbhd here and this is the
brand new galaxy s22 ultra i've been
using it for about two weeks now and i
promise you i'm not going to call this
the note 22 ultra over and over again in
this review i swear i can make it
through this video without making that
joke but really the bottom line here to
understand this phone the best really is
like if you took the name off of this
phone what samsung is giving you for the
money is a galaxy note but the phone
that i'm reviewing and using is called
the s22 ultra let's get into it so the
word ultra in samsung's lineup has
basically come to just mean the highest
ambitions the biggest numbers the best
specs and the most features overall it's
just that now the ultra name has
swallowed up the note stuff too so note
used to be that one special edition
phone with the squared off design the
flat top and bottom and the pen built in
now that's just all wrapped up into
ultra and the s22 ultra does not miss a
beat with all the ultra stuff they're
packing in the highest end ship they can
that's the snapdragon 8gen one here in
the us with a massive new cooling
solution alongside it the ram is
technically down from last year the base
model has eight gigs and all the rest
have 12 and there's no more 16 gig
version but i honestly don't miss that i
can't imagine someone really needing 16
gigs of ram in their phone right now but
you absolutely can go up to one terabyte
of non-expandable storage though but
this display this display is also
excellent it's a huge 6.8 inch 1440p
ammo led at 120 hertz with a 240 hertz
touch sample rate and the big new number
is a max brightness of
1750 nits now on the one hand i don't
want to overreact about 1750 nits like
it's a big number but brightness works
on a logarithmic scale so this 1750 is
not dramatically brighter than the 1500
max from last year's s21 ultra these
phones are all very sunlight readable
but i do still want to give samsung
credit for continuing to improve an
already best-in-class display and making
it even better it still got the same
great ultrasonic fingerprint reader as
last year right under the middle of the
screen and still has a hole punch camera
in the top middle and it's an ltpo2
panel now which means in addition to
being really responsive it can drop that
refresh rate as low as 1 hertz when
there's nothing moving on the screen
really my only dislike with this display
is the curve over the edges so if you
look at this phone next to last year's
s21 ultra obviously these phones are
different shapes and the displays are
actually slightly different resolutions
and this new shape definitely curves
more over the sides which i don't like
as much other than that this is an
awesome ultra display and we all know
it's not an ultra without a massive
battery so yeah 5000 milliamp hour
should do the trick now interestingly
there are some tests online showing that
it doesn't last as long as last year's
5000 milliamp hour battery and you can
see a roon mister who's the boss did a
variety of things in his test and found
the s21 ultra did last a bit longer than
this phone and to me when i see that i'm
like okay there's a variety of factors
that can contribute to that one the
slightly better display two a little bit
more of a power hungry chip that runs
hotter in the snapdragon 8 gen 1
but generally my battery experience has
been very very good i actually never
killed it in a day never really got
anywhere close easily ending heavy days
with 30 40 plus percent battery left and
could extrapolate about seven hours of
screen on time out of a charge which is
great for me i know screen on time is
different for everyone but it's been
great plus on top of that it does charge
a bit faster than last year up to 45
watt peak charging if you buy that fifty
dollar optional brick so i'm glad they
fit that big 5000 milliamp hour cell in
here despite also adding the s pen which
takes up a whole column along the inside
of the phone but speaking of that s pen
that's what's new the note stuff now i'm
personally not the biggest s pen user i
think i say this every time i review a
note like i think i signed one pdf last
week with it which was really convenient
but you know i did it once and i used
samsung's handwriting recognition in the
notes app super cool that it works
really well and you can search what
you've written
and i also
i just enjoy that it
still clicks a lot like that so it is
definitely impressive i still think it's
the best stylist in any phone and it's
literally got all the features the last
notes had smart select is nice for
screenshots and annotating things lock
screen quick notes are still super
convenient if you use samsung notes and
it even still has that long distance
bluetooth connection that lets you use
the button on the s pen to remote
control take photos without touching the
phone and the new display brings latency
down from nine milliseconds which is
already pretty good all the way down to
2.8 milliseconds which to me
basically feels like real time you know
i'm not an artist who's doing massive
drawings or extremely precise sketch
work with the pen it's just casual
writing
and so the fact that it uses ai to
predict where the pen is going to go and
starts drawing those pixels slightly
ahead of where the panel is actually
registering it is pretty next level so
to me this this is as close to one to
one as it gets but at the end of the day
if you see all this and you're like i
still probably won't really use any of
it then you can just slot the pen right
back into the phone and
never use it it's out of the way and the
phone didn't make any sacrifices to
include it so okay here's a bunch of
other smaller things that i noticed from
using this phone every day that you
should too if you're planning on getting
one so the speakers are excellent they
get very loud and sound crisp and clear
like last year some of the best in any
smartphone so that's great for watching
media but then the display curving more
over the edges than last year
makes it worse for watching videos and
then the vibration motor this is a small
thing but i mentioned it also in the s22
review they changed the type so it went
from a z-axis vibration motor to an
x-axis vibration motor it doesn't sound
like much but it changes the way it
feels so it feels just as strong and
precise and clean for typing or swiping
or holding it in your hand but it's way
less strong when it's on a desk or in
your pocket so i literally missed phone
calls with my phone sitting right in
front of me vibrating on my desk because
i didn't hear it or feel it
[Music]
then the camera rings so they're a bit
of a controversial design sure but like
most designs you kind of get used to
looking at it but you never
ever
fully get it clean of dust so if you go
caseless like me not only does the phone
sit kind of funny on a table but there
will also always be dust between the
camera rings so just get ready for that
i would actually recommend if you get a
case channel sponsor dbrand just dropped
their atomic edition grip case and it
doesn't do a huge cutout all the way
around the cameras like i thought we
might see in my impressions video it
actually just matches the camera rings
and it looks way cleaner and it's just
deep enough to protect the cameras if
you drop it
so this is definitely the way to go you
can check it out at the link below
then this phone just like the other s22s
shoots 8k video at 24 fps you know
the wrong frame rate give us the option
for 30 samsung just put it in the
settings somewhere but even worse than
not having the 30fps toggle it actually
crops in
way more than the regular s22s so turns
out shooting 8k is 33 megapixels and
it's actually cropping in to the middle
33 megapixels of this huge 108 megapixel
sensor so when you switch to 8k you zoom
in to what feels like about 2x which is
pretty inconvenient for framing no ak
video from the ultrawide or the
telephoto lenses this is a bit of a
downside and then there is absolutely
still some shutter lag with this main
camera more than the regular s22s again
and this is understandable with all the
processing happening but it definitely
felt like i was missing some shots or
having trouble capturing moving objects
because of the bit of a delay between
the shutter press and the actual photo
being taken but speaking of cameras
let's just get the camera stuff out of
the way
it's funny because this is probably what
most people actually come to these
review videos for if you think about it
if you watch a smartphone presentation
these days
75
of a new phone presentation today
especially a flagship is camera stuff so
that's one of the biggest things that
differentiates these phones and on a
1200 phone it's one of the most
important features
so how is it well you can see they went
with basically the same layout of this
set of cameras as last year it's 108
megapixel primary camera the ultra wide
the 3x telephoto and the 10x telephoto
plus laser autofocus and they're not the
same exact hardware as last year but
they're pretty close and that's a good
thing and samsung is not messing around
with their cameras these are definitely
flagship quality and i'm really happy
with them matter of fact i don't even
have much to say about image quality
because there really isn't much new here
but there are some new features
within the camera modes that might sort
of unlock some new things and be
different about this phone so i'm gonna
go over those with you one by one so
first the more accurate portrait mode
now
i think i tweeted a couple
months ago sort of ruffled some feathers
but i said something like samsung has
the best like portrait mode on
smartphones right now and
i understandably ruffled some feathers
but i should clarify basically what i
mean is their cutouts have been the most
consistent and the most accurate
of portrait modes among smartphones that
i've seen so that doesn't mean the the
blur is the most natural or the falloff
is the most realistic i just mean they
make the least errors with like ears and
hair and shirts and stuff
and so this year they're planning on
well they've announced that they're
doing it even better they've got ai
stereo depth mapping for portrait mode
that they claim can cut out things as
small as a single human hair
which would be cool it's not exactly
accurate but they say it's better so i
still found it to be really good but
it's definitely not perfect it still
misses some stuff sometimes but i stand
by my statement these cutouts and depth
mapping they're doing is really really
good the portrait mode shots especially
look good with the 3x lens with people
with pets even and also with inanimate
objects that still does a good job
cutting stuff out again not perfect
you'll pretty much always find some
error in every smartphone portrait mode
shot but samsung does a really good job
i think the 1x portrait shots are good
to have but they don't look as natural
so i hope samsung works on the
naturalness and fall off of the
background blur to overall make it the
best portrait mode then there is night
photography which samsung has called
nightography
okay so i compared the night mode shots
to the iphone 13 pro which also has an
excellent camera and my biggest takeaway
is yes samsung's night mode photos are
definitely more detailed 100
but they're also dramatically brighter
as advertised they're letting in a lot
of light and the photos in the dark look
like you're taking them in a lot more
light than you actually have especially
look at the sky back there so it's
impressive but it's also a bit of a
preference thing some people want their
nighttime photos to look like they're at
night but then lastly there is an expert
raw app separate from the camera app
that can take raw photos that includes
multi-frame computational photography
data hdr and everything and the
differences are subtle but they
absolutely do allow for more latitude
when editing so photographers should
definitely grab this app from the
ugliest app store i've seen in a while
the samsung galaxy store so i'm going to
end it with this you know typically the
big question with the review at the end
of the review you're like well should i
buy it is it worth it and this is an
expensive phone it's 1200 bucks so
that's a big question so basically i
think their mission was accomplished the
fact that they combined the note stuff
with this phone
makes it easier to separate from the
regular s22s it makes it a more
obviously different phone
in the lineup so if you just want like a
standard really good flagship phone big
screen nice battery nice cameras all
that stuff the s22 plus
is a great phone and it's 200 less at
the starting price
but if you want some specific extra
things like the super high resolution
display or the s pen or some of those
camera tweaks
then that gives you a reason to upgrade
and it does deliver on those extra
things now that being said i am sticking
with the galaxy s21 ultra as my main
daily driver phone obviously people who
have this phone don't need to upgrade
but it's just basically the same phone
as far as software battery cameras are
almost the same performance is the same
but uh with a design that i prefer and a
vibration motor that actually notifies
me more often but yeah overall this
phone is good it delivers if you want a
little bit of a more in-depth look at
the one ui 4.1 software and the fact
that this phone at least this lineup
with the s22 for samsung seems to be
basically the default android experience
more so than google's pixel ever could
be definitely watch my s22 review i'll
leave a like button if you want to watch
that real quick but that's been
basically it thanks for watching
catch you guys later
peace